♪ (music) ♪
(applause)
Hi, everyone. Thanks for coming today.
- My name is Daniel.
- My name is Nikhil.
We're from the Google Brain team,
and today we're delighted
to talk about JavaScript.
So, Python has been
one of the mainstream languages
for scientific computing,
and it's been like that for a while.
And there's a lot of tools
and libraries around Python.
But is that where it ends?
We're here today to talk--
to convince you that JavaScript
and the browser
have a lot to offer.
And TensorFlow Playground
is a great example of that.
I'm curious-- how many people
have seen TensorFlow Playground before?
Oh, wow! Quite a few.
I'm very glad.
So, for those of you that haven't seen it,
you can check it out after our talk
at playground.tensorflow.org.
It is an in-browser visualization
of a small neural network,
and it shows, in real time,
all the internals
of the network as it's training.
And this was a lot of fun to make.
It had a huge, educational success.
We've been getting emails
from high schools and universities
that have been using this
to teach students about machine learning.
After we launched Playground,
we were wondering,
"Why was it so successful?"
And we think one big reason
was because it was in the browser.
And the browser is this unique platform
where the things you build,
you can share
with anyone with just a link.
And those people that open your app
don't have to install any drivers
or any software,
it just works.
Another thing is the browser
is highly interactive,
and so the user is going to be engaged
with whatever you're building.
Another big thing is that browsers--
we didn't take advantage
of this in the Playground,
but browsers have access to sensors,
like the microphone and the camera
and the accelerometer.
All of these sensors
are behind standardized APIs
that work on all browsers.
And the last thing,
the most important thing,
is the data that comes from these sensors
doesn't ever have to leave the client.
You don't have to upload anything
to the server, which preserves privacy.
Now, the playground that we built
is powered by a small neural network,
300 lines of vanilla JavaScript
that we wrote as a one-off library.
It doesn't scale,
it's just simple for-loops,
and it wasn't engineered to be reusable.
But it was clear to us
that if we were to open the door
for people to merge
machine learning and the browser,
we had to build a library.
And we did it!
We released deeplearn.js,
a JavaScript library
that is GPU-accelerated
and it does that via WebGL,
which is a standard in the browser,
that allows you to render 3D graphics.
We utilize it to do linear algebra for us.
And deeplearn.js allows you to both
run inference in the browser
and training entirely in the browser.
When we released it,
we had an incredible momentum.
The community took deeplearn.js
and took existing models in Python,
imported it into the browser
and built interactive fun things with it.
So, one example is the Style Transfer.
Another person imported the character RNN,
and then built a novel interface
that allows you to explore
all the different
possible endings of a sentence,
all generated by the model in real time.
Another example
is a font-generative model--
there was a post about this.
The person that built it
allowed users to explore
the hidden dimensions,
the interesting dimensions
in the embedding space.
And you can see how they relate
to boldness and slantedness of the font.
And there were even educational examples,
like Teachable Machine
that built this fun little game
that taught people
how computer vision models work,
so people could interact
directly with the webcam.
Now, all the examples I showed you
point to the incredible momentum
we have with deeplearn.js.
And building on that momentum,
we're very excited today
to announce that deeplearn.js
is joining the TensorFlow family.
And with that, we are releasing
a new ecosystem of libraries and tools
for machine learning with JavaScript,
called TensorFlow.js.
Now, before we get into the details,
I want to go over three main use cases
of how you can use TensorFlow.js today,
with the tools and libraries
that we're releasing.
So, one use case is you can write models
directly in the browser,
and this has huge
educational implications--
think of the playground
that I just showed.
A second use case is--
a major use case is you can take
a pre-existing model,
pretrained model in Python,
use a script, and you can import it
into the browser to do inference.
And a related use case is the same model
that you take to do inference,
you can retrain it,
potentially with private data
that comes from those sensors
of the browser, in the browser itself.
Now, to give you more of a schematic view,
we have the browser that utilizes WebGL
to do fast, linear algebra.
On top of it, TensorFlow.js
has two sets of APIs:
the ops API,
which used to be deeplearn.js,
and we worked hard to align
the API with TensorFlow Python.
It is powered by an automatic
differentiation library
that is built analogous to Eager mode.
And on top of that,
we have a high-level API Layers API
that allows you to use best practices
and high-level building blocks
to write models.
What I'm also very excited
today to announce
is that we're releasing tools
that can take an existing Keras model
or TensorFlow SavedModel,
import it automatically
for execution in the browser.
Now, to show you an example of our API,
we're going to go over a small program
that tries to learn the coefficients
of a quadratic function.
So the coefficients we're trying to learn
are a, b, and c from data.
So we have our import tf
from TensorFlow.js.
For those of you that don't know,
this is a standard
ES6 import in JavaScript--
very common.
We have our three tensors: a, b, and c.
We mark them as variables,
which means that they are mutable
and the optimizer can change them.
We have our f(x) function
that does the polynomial computation.
You can see here familiar API,
like tf.add and tf.square,
like TensorFlow.
In addition to that API,
we also have a Chaining API
which allows you to call
these map operations on Tensors itself.
And this leads to better readable code
that is closer to how we write math.
Chaining is very popular
in the JavaScript world.
So that's the feed-forward
part of the model.
Now, for the training part,
we need a loss function.
So here is a loss function
that is just the mean-squared error
between the prediction and the label.
We have our optimizer, an sgd optimizer,
and we train the model--
we call optimizer.minimize
for some number of EPOCHS.
And here I want to emphasize,
for those of you
that have used tf.figure before
or the talk before us, Alex's talk,
the API in TensorFlow.js
is aligned with the Eager API in Python.
Alright, so clearly that's not how
most people write machine learning,
because those low-level linear
algebra ops can be quite verbose.
And for that, we have our Layers API.
And to show you an example of that,
we're going to build
a recurrent neural network
that learns to sum two numbers.
But the complicated part
is that those numbers,
like the number 90+10,
are being fed character by character.
And then the neural network
has to maintain an internal state
with an LSTM cell.
That state then gets passed
into a decoder,
and then the decoder has to output 100,
character by character.
So it's a sequence-to-sequence model.
This may sound a little complicated,
but with the Layers API
is not that many lines of code.
We have our import tf from TensorFlow.js.
We have our sequential model,
which just means it's a stack of layers.
For those of you that are familiar
with tf.layers in Python or Keras,
this API looks very familiar.
The first two layers are the encoder,
the last three layers are the decoder.
And that's our model.
We then compile it
with a loss, an optimizer,
and a metric we want to monitor,
like accuracy,
and we call model.fit, with our data.
Now, what I want to point out here
is the await keyword.
So, model.fit is an asynchronous call,
which means--
because in practice that can take
about 30 or 40 seconds in a browser.
And in those 30 or 40 seconds,
you don't want the main UI thread
of the browser to be locked.
And this is why you get a callback
with a history object after that's done.
And in between, the GPU
is going to do the work.
Now, the code I showed you
is when you are trying
to write models directly--
when you want to write models
directly in the browser.
But, as I said before, a major use case,
even with deeplearn.js
was people importing models
that were pretrained,
and they just want to do
inference in the browser.
And before we jump
into the details of that,
I want to show you a fun little game
that our friends
at Google Brand Studio built
that takes advantage
of an automatically pretrained model
ported into the browser.
And the game is called
Emoji Scavenger Hunt.
And the way it works--
I'm going to show you here
a real demo with the phone.
It's in the browser.
Let me see.
Can I see here?
So you can see I have a Chrome browser
opened up on a Pixel phone.
You can see the URL on the top.
And the game uses the webcam
and shows me an emoji,
and then I have some time,
some number of seconds
to find the real version
item of that emoji
before the time runs out.
So, before we play,
Nikhil here is going to help me identify
the objects that this game asks.
- You ready?
- (Nikhil) I'm ready.
(Daniel) Alright, let's go.
(countdown beeping)
- Alright. Watch. Do you have a watch?
- (Nikhil) I have a watch.
(phone) Did I spot a velvet?
Go on.
- (Daniel) Whoo! Yay! We got that!
- (Nikhil) Awesome.
(Daniel) Let's see what our next item is.
(countdown beeping)
- (Daniel) Shoe.
- (Nikhil) Shoe.
(Daniel) You got
to help me out here, buddy.
- (phone) Did I spot a--
- (Daniel) Oh, yeah!
- (phone) You found shoe.
- (Daniel) Whoo! We got the shoe!
(Nikhil) Alright, what's next?
(countdown beeping)
(Daniel) Right, it wants a banana.
(Nikhil) A banana? Does anyone have a--
this guy's got a banana!
- (Daniel) Hold, what!
- (Nikhil) This guy's got a banana!
- (Daniel) Come over here.
- (phone) Am I seeing a wall?
- (Daniel) Yay! Alright!
- (Nikhil) Alright!
- (Daniel) Look at us!
- (Nikhil) I'm ready.
We're going to have a high score here.
- (Daniel) Beer!
- (phone) Could that be a hat?
(Nikhil) It's 10:30
in the morning, Daniel!
- (phone) Did I spot a velvet?
- (Nikhil) Let's get back to the talk.
- (Daniel) Alright. (chuckles)
- (phone) I think I saw a milk can.
(Nikhil) Alright, so I'm going to jump
into the technical details
of how we actually built that game.
The clicker? Yep.
So, what we did was we trained
the model in TensorFlow
to be an object recognizer
for the Scavenger Hunt game.
We chose about 400 different classes
that would be reasonable
for a game like this,
you know, watches and bananas and beer.
So, what we did was we used
the TensorFlow For Poets codelab.
And in that codelab,
what you essentially do
is you take a pretrained MobileNet model.
And if you don't know what MobileNet is,
it's a state-of-the-art computer
vision model for edge devices.
So what we effectively did
was we took that model
and we retrained it for these classes.
Now we have an object detector
in the Python world.
How do we actually
now get this into the browser?
Well, we provide a set of tools today
that help you actually do that.
Once it's in, you skin the game
and you make the computer talk
and all that kind of fun stuff.
Let's jump into how
we actually can convert that model.
So, as Daniel mentioned earlier today,
we actually support two types of models,
so we support TensorFlow SavedModels--
we have a converter for that.
And we also have a converter
for Keras SavedModels.
So you define your model
and you save it with a Save model--
this is a standard way to do that.
Similarly, this is a code
that you would do that for Keras
[inaudible].
The next piece is that
we actually convert it to the Web.
Today, we're releasing a pit package.
It's TensorFlow.js,
you can install that there.
There's a script in there
that lets you point
to your TensorFlow SavedModel,
and point to an output directory,
and that output directory
will be where those static
build artifacts will go for the web.
Keras is the same exact flow.
Point to you HDF5 input
and you have an output directory
where those [build artifacts] will go.
Now you statically host those
on your website somewhere,
you know, just simple static hosting.
And on the JavaScript side, we provide
an API that lets you load that model.
So this is what it looks like
for a TensorFlow.
In the TensorFlow SavedModel
you'll notice that it's a frozen model,
we don't right now support
continuing training of this model.
While in the Keras case,
we actually let you continue training,
and we're working hard to keep
these APIs aligned in the future.
Okay, so under the cover,
what are we actually doing?
So we're doing some graph optimization,
which essentially means
that we prune out nodes
that you don't need
to make the prediction,
you don't need that on the web.
We optimize waits
for browser autocaching,
so we pack in shard in chunks of 4MB
which helps your browser be quick
the next time your page loads.
Today, we support about 90
of the most commonly-used TensorFlow ops,
and we're working very hard
to support more, like control flow ops.
And we support 32
of the most commonly-used
Keras layers today.
And as I mentioned, we let
you continue training for Keras models,
and we let you do evaluation,
as well as make predictions
from that model.
Okay, so obviously,
there's a lot you can do,
with just porting your models
to the web for inference.
But since the beginning of deeplearn.js,
we've made it a high priority
to make sure that you can
train directly in the browser.
This opens up the door for education
and interactive tools
like we saw with the playground,
as well as let you train with data
that never leaves your client.
So this is huge for privacy.
So you show off what you can do
with something like this,
we've built another little game.
So, the goal of the game
is to play Pac-Man with your webcam.
Now, Daniel's going to be my helper here.
He is much, much better at this game
than I am for some reason.
Just say, "Hi!"
So, there are three phases of the game.
Phase 1-- we're going
to collect frames from the webcam
and we're going to associate those
with up, down, left, and right,
these classes.
Now Daniel's going to move
his head up, down, left, and right,
and he's just simply going
to play the game like that.
And you'll notice,
as he's collecting frames,
he's kind of moving around a little bit.
This kind of helps the model
see different angles for that class
and generalize a little bit better.
So after he's done
collecting these frames,
we're going to go and train our model.
So we're not actually training
from scratch here
when we hit that Train button.
We're taking a pretrained MobileNet again,
porting that to the web,
and doing a retraining phase
with that data that's local,
and we're using the Layers API
to do that in a browser here.
Do you want to press that Train button?
Alright. Our loss is going down--
looks like we're learning something.
That's great.
So, as soon as we press that Play button,
what's going to happen is we're going
to make predictions from the webcam--
those are going to get plugged
into those controls
and it's going to control
the Pac-Man game.
Ready?
Alright, so you can see
in the bottom right,
it's highlighting the class
that it thinks it is.
And Daniel, if he moves his head around,
you'll see it change [by] class.
And he's off.
(laughter)
So... (chuckling)
all of this code is online,
and you can go fork it--
we invite you to do so.
And obviously, this is just a game.
But you can imagine other types
of applications of this,
like make a browser extension
that lets you control the page
for accessibility purposes.
So again, all this code is online.
Please go fork it, and play
and make something else with it.
- Okay, Daniel. I know this is fun.
- (Daniel) I gotta? Alright.
(laughter) (applause)
You've got to get back to the talk.
Okay, so let's talk a little bit
about performance.
So what we're looking at here
is a benchmark of MobileNet 1.0
running with TensorFlow--
this is TensorFlow classic,
not with TensorFlow.js.
I want to point out here,
we're using a batch size of 1.
This is important
because we're thinking about this
in the context
of an interactive application,
so maybe this Pac-Man game
where you feed in webcam data,
you want to know
what the prediction time is for 1.
You can't really batch things.
On the top row, we're looking
at TensorFlow CUDA
running on a 1080GTX--
this is a beefy machine.
It's about three milliseconds.
I want to point out--
the shorter the bar,
the faster it is, clearly.
On the second row we have TensorFlow CPU,
and this is running with AVX-512,
and this is on actually
one of these MacBook Pros here.
It's about 60 milliseconds for that frame.
Where does TensorFlow.js
fit into this picture?
Well, it depends.
If you're running on a beefy 1080GTX,
we're actually getting
about 11 milliseconds
for one pass through this MobileNet model,
which is pretty good
if you think about this
in the context of an interactive game.
So, on the laptop that we just
showed the game with,
we're getting about 100 milliseconds
for that inference,
passed through MobileNet.
That's still pretty good.
You can build a whole interactive game
with something that's running
at 100 milliseconds.
So the web is only going to get
faster and faster.
There's a whole new set
of standards coming, like WebGPU,
that will really push the boundary
for these kinds of things.
But the browser still has its limitations.
You can only really get access
to the GPU through WebGL on these APIs.
So, how do we scale beyond that?
How do we scale beyond the limitations
that we have in the browser?
There's a whole ecosystem
of server-side JavaScript tools
using node.js that we would love
to take advantage of.
So today, I'm really happy to tell you
that we're working on node.js bindings
to the TensorFlow C API.
What that means is you'll be able to write
that same low-level ops API
with the Eager mode
we saw with the polynomial example,
or the high-level Layers API
which we saw for the Pac-Man example,
and bind to TensorFlow C,
and run head lists in your TensorFlow
running with CUDA installed.
Eventually, that also means we can run
with a TPU on a backend--
that same JS code.
So these bindings
are underactive developments,
so stay tuned for more.
Alright, so let's recap some of the things
that we launched today
and that we talked about.
So we talked about this low-level ops API
which does hardware-
accelerated linear algebra
as well as the Eager mode
differentiation for autograd.
This was previously known as deeplearn.js.
We're re-branding that today.
We released the high-level Layers API.
This is the Keras-inspired API
that mirrors TensorFlow Layers,
and we saw an example
of that with the addition RNN,
and we saw an example of that
with the Pac-Man demo.
We also showed you how you can import
TensorFlow SavedModels,
and Keras models for prediction
and retraining in the browser.
We also have released a bunch of demos
and examples on Github.
These are not the only two--
there's a whole repository
of different examples
that can get you started,
and they'll have live links
so you can go and poke around and play.
So I invite you to go do that.
So we really want
to see you get involved in this project.
We have a bunch of links here,
so js.tensorflow.org
is our official website.
All of these links,
everything we've talked about is there--
there's tutorials,
there's documentation, etc.
Our code is obviously open-sourced
under tensorflow/tfjs.
So I invite you to go play there too.
And we also started
a community mailing list today--
that's the short link here.
And the community
mailing list is for people
to post demos and ask questions,
and that kind of thing.
So this project
was not just Daniel and myself,
this was a larger team effort
between many of our amazing
colleagues at Google.
So we want to thank them.
We also want to thank
all of the amazing open-source
contributors for deeplearn.js.
And we're really excited
to build the next chapter
of machine learning
and JavaScript with you.
- Thank you
- (Daniel) Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪